hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast oscillations deep brain
stimulation and a functional Network is
G de la Tourette syndrome presented by
Roche anak hashemian PhD I'm charissa
meraz of lab Ruth and I will be your
moderator for today's event lab routes
is the leading scientific social
networking site and we are extremely
proud to bring you this interactive web
seminar for more information visit us at
libraries calm here's how this
presentation will work today we want to
hear from you questions comments and
even answers can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen we'll try to get to everyone
but if not we will make sure to follow
up with you by email you can also
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you cannot
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button at the top right or the Q&A
button in the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credit after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Rocha Ngoc hashemian
dr. Hashim Yoon is the head of the human
brain and behavior laboratory in the
department of stereotactic and
functional neurosurgery at the
University Hospital of Cologne in
Germany her work unites scientific
research in clinical care if focuses on
identifying the altered network dynamics
underlying this is functional brain
states of neuropsychiatric and
neurologic disorders as well as fosters
the development of novel treatments
which alleviate the symptoms of these
disorders please join me in welcoming
dr. Hashimi Yoon
I will now turn the presentation over to
her
haha Thank You Julie for that very kind
introduction and thank you to my glutes
for inviting me to give a presentation
today on oscillations deep brain
stimulation and the functional Network
and children at our corner my talk today
will focus on identifying the network
dynamics giving rise to Gerrard syndrome
in particular I want to explore with you
the expression of oscillations and their
aberration in the dysfunctional
circuitry of the cortical basal ganglia
or cortical loop and how that's
correlated with yoga direct or GPS and
dermatology further you will see how the
events of deep brain stimulation
technology can serve not only to remedy
but to assess the pathophysiology of
j'tia so um we need to define a new
light red syndrome and unfortunately
doesn't have a definitive diagnostic
test
so it's classified based on the
observation of symptoms the symptoms are
criteria and necessary for diagnosis are
childhood onset it's usually diagnosed
between the ages of four and seven years
old multiple motor tics and at least
work on taken eight the term chronic
intentionally because some of these
ticks do not engage the vocal cords and
also it must be persistent for at least
one year and not attributable to drugs
or other medical causes so um we're
talking a lot about ticks in the
clinical diagnosis of direct and the
cover guys it's important to define them
properly
ticks are sudden purposeless and
repetitive and can be either motor or um
tonic so some examples of motor tics and
groove blinking shoulder shrugging
grimacing jumping obscene gestures using
and self-injurious behavior and example
the five kicks are pro clearing with
we are barking sniffing the subsonic
Mach 1 and you're yelping so how do you
say this descriptive definition of did
yes I want to show you the human face of
it the follow that is a courtesy of
stage 2 an unproductive production the
doctors it is archival footage from 2010
can you have the video please oh I
remember
he's trying to keep my mouth shut or
keep my leg still and I couldn't I
couldn't Miss Manners my back my home I
started to get scared
we took tie into a child psychiatrist
and he said you don't need me you need a
neurologist I was officially diagnosed
with Tourette after I just turned 10
years old the tics snowballs into
painful self-abusive tics very fast it
really started hitting yourself in the
stomach in the chest he would snap his
head forward so violently that he ended
up with a bruise on his chest bone and a
bruise under exchange oh well just to me
I just want to show them the bruise
burner Oh keep your chin up - what's
that bruise from my chest he is my kid
like it out there what is good up you
throw himself on the floor I spent
countless hours curl up in a ball crying
because I didn't know what to do if he
was trapped in this no matter where he
was
[Music]
going to school drove me out of my mind
I didn't know how to cope with it come
on I need to go come to chew better ah
there are big gaps of his education I'm
feeling terrible when I go I eventually
started chewing through my cheek and it
swelled up really big so I wore a mouth
guard or just stick a washcloth wanted
as much as I could into my mouth I've
dug my fingers into my eyes son became a
word that was kind of just imaginary I
just hurt so bad that my son was home on
the couch in protective gear missing
life that's left scars I mean I had
suicidal thoughts no matter what we
tried there just wasn't anything out
there that would keep it I felt very
hopeless and without anything to turn to
so I suppose he directs can be extremely
debilitating unfortunately it's also
associated with corporal area which
actually only affects a small percentage
of the patient population and this is
when people learn out obscenities etc
but it can be quite physically
debilitating and very painful for the
patient and those around them the direct
has a range of symptoms which you've
seen and they can be expressed
differently different times and we saw
the changes in symptom
type severity and location in the video
but to still also vary in their
frequency number and complexity and the
sweat flowing the symptoms is low to do
as the constant changes into the
expression to confound the therapy
subscribe
use the clinical observation of lexing
lineal symptoms over time can also be
expressed computational as a periodic
higher-order combination of tip outs and
that's what you see here the temporal
occurrence of ticks can be statistically
characterized as fractal now the
expression of so acceptance with the DTS
might also be attributed to its
correlated ease which can occur at up to
80% with such disorders as ADHD and OCD
but there are also many limited
disorders associated with tracks such as
anxiety rage and depression so it's
important to remember that tics of
attracts is a disorder possessing both
motor and related Coppola's so um I mean
sometimes in this light here there we go
the cortical basal ganglia cortical loop
that we discuss in the made of multiple
parallel circuits which we moved for
their cortical areas of oranges here
dkc3 affect the motor circuit the
associative circuit and the limbic
circuit and he's irrelevant for GPS or
the neuropsychiatric disorders now these
pathways communicate information
relevant to the functions that they're
labeled and the information is cemented
topically transmitted with generally the
motor circuits composing the dorsal
lateral stream of the dorsal our
division and the eunich circuit
composing the ventral medial screen for
the projections from the frontal quote
from the frontal cortex followed this
topographic organization through the
subcortex
and each circuit is devoted to its
discrete behavioral function that means
that the dorsal and the ventral streams
are relaying very different information
although there are some regions in which
the information flow between a second
pathways and that allows for new
behaviors from the integration of
information from the different parallel
pathways so to take on less extreme need
to know is if the part of a real family
is a rather large network besides being
an uncle and it's composed of multiple
circuits the three that we see here for
example and they're more and it's
well-positioned to integrate motor
cognitive and affective motor processes
so all right there's a very nice
visualization modified here from London
and Al where you can better see the
structures of the basal ganglia that are
the core of the cortical basal getting
on the part and you can see that
together here with us our lives this
figure gives a good feel for this
intimate physical arrangement of all of
these so the basal ganglia here you can
see up on the top left are composed of
Australia which is the quiet
entertainment the that's the red and
blue the Globus pallidus just under a
next to it in the experiencing in like a
purple and the interesting green and
then you see a very large thalamus and
underneath that is the supplies a
nucleus and the substantial eyebrow the
Baker gang they received massive
projections from really all the
functions of divisions of the cortex and
then through its appearance to the
Gallants connects back to the better
part of the entire neocortex now I'm
going to show you a video together to
give you a better feel for the essential
role of the basal ganglia and the larger
network in their central position in the
brain this video you nice to be able to
see the spatial relationship of this
with Romania and the larger network will
see you I want you to notice the size
and position of the network because
you'll see the tip for the turquoise
route all the other structures you'll
see will be visualized in some colors
and that
compartment reason ganglia which sits at
the base of the forebrain and spans the
midbrain together with the thalamus it
fills up the majority of the
diencephalon so it really takes up a
very central area in the brain so if I
can have the video please
so I hope that gave you a pretty good
feel for what the size and position of
the circuit really is in the brain and
how important it is how essential it is
to function really originally thought to
be mainly involved in involuntary
movement and movement coordination but
are now known to be active in learning
memory and habit formation
so no sign of that so here what you see
a schematic of the network so you can
clearly see here that the parts of the
PDP s CB GTC part of a band some apart
loop are highly into correct
interconnected in these structures and
what should be noted here is that the
striatum and the STAAR salandrich
nucleus are the implications of the
basal ganglia and the GPI Group spouse
internist and snr suspension Hydra of
parasitic on are the only output
stations and that the author of the
basal ganglia is predominantly going to
the thalamus what this information gets
from the Globus pallidus the GP is NR
premise item is described in two
pathways known as a direct and indirect
pathway now in this slide here you see
the the direct pathway is highlighted in
beige and you'll see that those right
under should not fit in between the
cortex and accepted ether in service
lavinia through either I think that the
director indirect pathway and here in a
direct pathway you can see that it goes
straight to the cortex goes right on to
the GPI
and then over to the SNR and I'm sorry
like over to the thalamus back up to the
cortex here in the indirect pathway you
have a polished fantastic connection
between us try them in the GPIO sonar
and the cheerless in
pathway beaters double receptors are
expressed whereas in the back in the
direct pathway you have a d1 receptor
mediated halfway in this mono synaptic
connection from the strident PGP is more
now trick expression is thought to be
the result of excessive activation of
the direct versus the indirect pathway
which explains the success of d2
antagonists and leading tips there is
also a third major pathway known as the
hyper direct pathway which you see here
highlighted in purple and bypasses the
here the information in the cortex
bypasses Australia and a lot of the
cortex to powerfully excite the gpio
Sonoran with fast conduction times and a
widespread divergent activation so
together these pathways are suggested to
act to select a desired motor program
and inhibit undesired motor actions and
what is known as this center-surround
model for action selection so this model
incorporates the complex range of
activation patterns mediating beta
ganglia functions that arise from both
varying time scales as well as a
differential anatomical connections so
how does that work
first you can see that the cortex is
possibly transmitting information
through the fast conducting hyper direct
pathway which works on a faster times
known as we mentioned than the direct
pathway and they also projects more
diffusive indirect pathway which means
is providing a general expectation over
a large population of the GPI output
neurons or the surrounding walls which
are either competing or unwanted motor
action since they're not the selected
motor program so the cause to the
desired motor program has been
transmitted securely through the direct
pathway which is a little more slow and
but more focused to the center neuron
the GPI then these inhibit the release
this inhibit the thalamus and release
the desired order program so you can see
the the spike activity of the neurons in
each of these pathways on the left and
the right of the sorry I have a pointer
of the side so the father point of this
tripartite behavior a polite expectation
of the desire ons from the signal
transmission of the through the indirect
pathway and it's this mechanism I don't
think that's hypothesized to effectuate
precision initiation and termination of
the selected motor programs and in this
way we inhibit unwanted or compete or
competing one so the integration so it's
important to realize that the
integration information between these
circuits is how you can get something
from the work of example importantly
probably circuits that suggested to the
essential for actually selection and
also the conversion of goal directed
behaviors to automated behaviors so it's
really the balance of the normal
balances and the basal ganglia function
that gives us proper coordination
some balance between the direct and
indirect pathway going to do surveys and
that balance or that coordination could
lead to the changes that results in the
hypo or hyper kinetic disorders that um
that we observe including a Tourette's
syndrome so this is an example of a
hypokinetic dysfunction that's expressed
and the only ones to communities that we
observe in GPS and here is not excessive
dopamine inhibiting dangerous
way leading the direct pathway unopposed
and releasing spontaneous and
uncontrollable glutes now proper
coordinated activity is the relevant
network leads to the observed behavior
and macroscopic scale via faithful
transmission of information but what
mode of communication might networks
used to accomplish this oscillation so
oscillations are suggested to be the
meaning by which of different brain
areas communicate with each other
and cooperativity between neurons we
translated into the physiological
spatial temporal pattern of activity
observed in oscillations so here you can
see a simulation of an oscillation this
is a 10 Hertz frequency the upper panel
shows the spiking of individual neurons
with each stop representing an
individual actual potential within the
population and the lower panel is a
local field potential that reflects
their son back to me frequency frequency
that we observe only say things like a
10 Hertz oscillation etc this results in
the solve the rhythm of the network so
important to understand an oscillation
results not just from it results from
the coordinated activity from announced
on board neuron not just one neuron
firing during each cycle but if the
unsolveable could synchronize their
fluctuations within an acceptable
boundary range so it's very important to
keep a temporal order here so there's
structure in the correlation of their
activity and the amplitude that you see
in the local field potential is a result
of how many neurons are participating in
producing the oscillation so
oscillations are thought to be crucial
to your location they're ubiquitous in
the brain and they're found correlated
with all kinds of
brain function like cognition vision
sensation perceptual input motor output
speech and even thought but what happens
when good synchrony goes bad you get
impaired communication of course and
this abnormal synchronization is what's
located in brain disorders so it's kind
of like the can you hear me now when
you're the followed someone and they're
talking really loudly the information
comes in distorted to you because
there's too much noise this is too much
synchrony and the information is coming
in you can think of it that way so this
is what I think of as a hyper synchron's
when someone's talking very tightly on
the phone you don't hear them very well
and you need to speak up a little as
opposed to the formula can we bring it
down a little and that's a analogous to
hypo synchrony so I just think of it in
those terms of the house so in the case
of whooping crane you have buffay's
relations and the mutual interaction
occurs or face here as you can see where
the the marked black lines are a good
neutral interactions which is her in
phase allows for the most faithful
transmission of information but what
happens again as you said limbic
synchrony goes back in the case of back
synchrony you can have something like
hyper synchronization and this is the
kind of thing that's important with
several disorders including Parkinson's
tinnitus androgenic pain and what you
can see if you look at the red arrow
that's moving showing time moving to the
right and each of those dots again are
an action potentials in your arm and you
can see that as time progresses when
this group phase relation continues you
get an increase in mutual information as
you can see underneath in green and I
should get an increase in you to
information because the phase relations
are together for even
we're all very longer you can decrease
in information coding capacity and that
correlates to an increase in the local
field potential amplitude as we've a
different frequency that you're looking
at so if something is sensitive to
signaling here you can see that the
changes into green can be modulated by
different mechanisms across the networks
such as changes in your transmitter
levels and you talk about dopamine so at
the bottom you can see that there is
don't really appreciate it's moving to
the right the top trace is of d2 and the
bottom one is you also going back to the
rule that we discussed in the correlated
angle thumbprint loop you can see the
effect of the decrease in dopamine on a
simulated model of the straddle ah
neural microcircuit so you can see in
the upper raster that the activity of
the purpose of the neurons participating
in the B to Network are increasing and
becoming more synchronized and the
different gets depleted and the lower
one which is the d1 network
you see that that synchronous is falling
apart it's decreasing and you please
this excuse me this a decrease in a
level of dopamine regulation is
correlated can be correlated or the
increase can be correlated with the
function of the straddle network so that
in the bottom layer almost at a state of
randomness and the top one it's like a
pathological synchronization so this
sort of aberrant oscillations can be
seen in high personal printing or hypo
synchrony within specific frequency
bands as oscillations phenotypes that
are correlated with various disorders
and there are two examples here there's
Parkinson's and autism in figure a
you're looking at a depth profile of the
spectral power relative to the
subthalamic nucleus or STM door
order there's a microelectrode
recordings there's a mapping that's
going on during a microelectrode
recording of the SPN here during what's
called a DBS or deep brain stimulation
procedure and that risk reveals a
frequency map with a strong or hyper
synchronized beta oscillation you can
see that their beta because of this dark
red area between at about 25 Hertz and
in figures needs you can see there's a
these are artistic paper EEG for
artistic patients or patients on the ASU
spectrum autistic spectrum and that's at
the bottom and this is at the top of the
controller thing could be and here this
is you can see the typography
distribution for the gala band spectral
power during the perception of a movie
base which you see on the left under the
only overview and you can see that the
galvanic signal is expressed as a hypo
synchrony in the lower case of the
patients who have autism versus the
controls at the top now and they show a
much lower gallop power as compared to
the control group
now you can treat these different
disorders by various means there's
pharmacological methods unfortunately
many of the drugs have intolerable side
effects or lose their efficacy over time
there's behavioral therapy which can be
very effective in the case of Tourette's
unfortunately they are not still very
many properly trained therapists in CIT
which is very effective protect and in
cases where patients become medically
refractory or treatable factory we can
help surgery and this is what happened
in the case of Thailand if you saw in
the video earlier resurgent was the
option now one type of surgery that has
become quite popular and very effective
and reversible is deep brain stimulation
this is a relatively new surgery four
years old and in different simulation
you have invasive surgical procedure
which target specific areas of the brain
and those areas will elect reduced when
electrically stimulated will provide a
symptom illogical relief for the given
disorder it is invasive this disorder
specific and there are deep targets for
this and we have what's called an
effective pacemaker with lead wires that
have electric honor so if you look to
the far right you'll see these two lead
wires and very small so we're not sun
running over the electrodes I should
post what those away those are if you
follow the URL doors are connected to
extension um wires and that is connected
the extension are that connected to the
implantable pulse generator we also
survey sent to the target and that
should perturb the network leaving the
patient into a better functional state
now this is that process that I promised
you from these electrodes and what we
should see here are these these are two
different standard electrodes that use
quite often bone and in to notice here
or the actual electrodes or what we call
the lead electrodes another terminology
nuances using and the cylindrical server
appoint pieces that you see are the
actual electrodes that provide the
electrical stimulation to the brain
target and they can call me different
spacings that you can see also the local
context the right way so um there are
two differents along the back so I'm
going to show you a video that explains
to you visually unfortunate
speak while the video is on there's
arrangement that we just discussed where
there is a lead electrode that is
incited into a target that's specific
for the disorder and how that is
connected to infection wire that
extension wire they get pledges on other
the scalpers behind the year under the
skin down left and is connected to the
implantable pulse generator which is
implanted itself particularly sometime
please have the video which will show
this looks like
thank you very much
so what you could see there is the
continuous stimulation that goes from
the battery in the central pulse
generator up through the wires into the
deep brain target now that came when
that happens where the wires are
connected to both sides and stimulate
both sides of the brain one is ICG or
impact or implantable pulse generator
that is a bilateral system and when
there's one for either hemisphere that
is called a unilateral system once you
remember that because that's going to
come over in just a second now the goal
of DBS is to rebalance the coordination
matrix in the neural circuit so it's
neuromodulatory there's a direct
alteration of the neural activity and
this will be quite effective going back
to our figure where we saw the hyper
synchronised data oscillations if you
look at penalty um these are the
Parkinson's patients again and here um
you can see will be that the hyper
synchronize oscillations in the
subthalamic nucleus are have a very high
power in the function okay sorry in the
LFP so if you remember earlier where we
had our red arrow with the raster plot
where as you went further down in timing
it this really good prolonged base
relations that you got an increase in
synchrony and that increase in recently
in a mutual interaction causes decrease
and information coding capacity but
remember that causing an increase in the
local field potential amplitude at that
frequency in that what you're seeing
here and B now with continuous
stimulation if you look
panel see what happens is that
continuous BBS drops tremendously the
power of that LSD and that happens
because you're now establishing normal
things relations presumably the neutral
information is at a proper balance and
then information for any capacity we
imagine goes up and this is why you see
an improvement in the symptomatology
but without tourettes so in case of
Parkinson's we found that the dynamic
coordination that was expressed
pathologically in the correlative
activity of the neural network was
representative of the dysfunction and
was corrected by altering the dynamic
face structure of those participating
neurons as I just explained so in other
words important settings as well in many
other disorders it's demonstrated that
our oscillations are correlated with
symptomatology now this might be the
case in all disorders and certainly
helping to attract so while we do have
some insight from the pathophysiology
tracks we still have not really like a
real understanding at kick theology or
took Genesis so we write to in oil if
oscillations play some role since they
seem to be significant for other
disorders for example black children
Parkinson's or what we saw earlier an
autism we'd like to know it's correct to
be a disorder of synchrony there are
theories that maybe to Genesis could be
the result of high personal training our
vision drives oscillations because
between students and other disorders but
we don't even know of Tourette's really
is a disorder of synchrony so we set out
to answer some of these questions and to
see what the effects of oscillation I'm
sorry to see the role of oscillations in
the fact of physiologist arrest which is
following panel going to the left to see
what the chronic effects were or are
on the network and also to see if there
any short-term effects that are also
indicative of the chronic effects we've
done to get those answers we need to be
able to report chronically from
implanted DBS patients then what we
thought is that the line of DBS could
make it correct the dysfunction in the
signal transmission know what there is
today no one has done project Orioles in
no one has done chronic recordings
interesting and because there wasn't the
technology available so new york-based
have developed a device which could
record as long as a minute not devices
what I'm showing you here we were a
speedy escalators capable of responding
stimulation and recording of these on
local field potentials postoperatively
so we could get chronic
electrophysiological record loss during
the entire time and it was implanted
local field potentials could be
transmitted wirelessly from the nerve
place implants which contains a
processor that has a memory buffer so
that we could hold the recorded data and
that data would be transmitted on was
transmitted by a telemetry my eternity
blog I was connected to a computer so
this is this is what that looks like in
the case of the North paced device
you'll notice that unlike the other GPS
devices which I showed you an example
this one gets implanted in the cranium
and indoor saliva as you mentioned has
various capabilities that other devices
did not have at that time and actually I
think there's still no commercially
available device that does allow for
private recordings the DBS now
to this lock so um we use this device
and based on multiple factors about the
least of which is a patient's symptoms
there different areas or targets as we
discussed earlier in the brain that we
could stimulate so it's really important
to be able to identify if we could know
the proper target if we can identify the
brain circuit that's malfunctioning
where we could best effect that
malfunction in the circuit when we could
maybe modulator manipulate that area and
and then use the patient's into his or
her best functional state so finding the
most efficacious target is paramount in
actually target selection is one of the
most dated issues in deep brain
stimulation today which the brain
structure structures will yield the best
possible outcome and in an GPS there are
three major targets for consideration
there's the thalamus which was the first
target that was used in EDX
there's the Globus pallidus the GP and
also the nucleus accumbens the GP is
often preferred for motor relief of GPS
symptoms and the pendulum of the
internal capsule / mr. Cummings oh it's
called a ventral capsule dementia
struggle for to relieve some of the
limbic symptoms of the disorder so what
we did some slide issues here technical
difficulties what we did in our study
was to take five subjects that were
treatment refractory and we use the
narrow case device and perform the
chronical Corning's
and especially in the aggressive amounts
we pick that as a target and we looked
at the local field potentials now the
clinical metrics that we used for the
symptomatology
in order to be able to
aurélie behavioral manifestations the
disorder with the underlying or
physiology or the 11 FPS with what's
called the Y the Yale robotics very
scale which is the y GPFS that was a
cool electric and this is one page event
so you have an idea of what that looks
like and here is a CT MRI so you cannot
write idea how we did the target
localization that it was verified by
September aircraft and just relies you
one more time
of the bilateral versus the unilateral
school later and because we actually
never using both in our patients and you
Electra configuration that we had for
that so usually part of a foreign team
we try to look sorry you know the kind
of recordings you try to look at how
these impairment was improves and we
correlated that if the underlying
physiology in the network an item nation
and the way that we did that was by
looking at the spectral power in the
local field potentials living in the
back was by looking at the activity
across contact pairs over time so if you
look in the case where we had a
bilateral stimulator
channel one to unfertile lot was drive
between electrodes going to contact
relatives way to channel two was for
electrodes three and four and then in
the other hemisphere channel one to of
our electrode one two or child three and
let's between former child for now in
the case of the neurostimulator into one
device probe right hemisphere electrodes
one to comprise channel Y
electrodes two and three comprise shell
two electric strings for comparison l3
and then electrodes one to four
commercial for and here you can see that
we have the largest selling of the
neuronal population or the network
electronic network and and what we end
up finding a world firstly the structure
and the coordination of the neural
activity right this is what we're
already discussing and you saw that what
I should use a raster of the ten Hertz
frequency and we LP electrical
stimulation alters the destruction then
you can explore the theories in several
hyper hyper synchronization areas ggs
about the role of oscillations interest
and how that can be corrected after the
via therapy and the way that we do that
is by looking at those speeds which is
what we see on the right side
parallelize so what we found is that
there is a clinical benefit that was
correlated with an increase in the
galvanic power so this actually implies
that there was a high pollen grain not a
high person training each other the
coordination matrix of the our neurons
was are too loosely connected instead of
those really the phase relations being
sustained increasing over time we would
have actually the opposite where those
phase relations but who are and um I'm
gonna show you some water spots here in
this case we have a patient which has a
very high logic TSS of night several 100
the highest it means it's the worst and
in this patient we can see um that their
shuttle 1 2 3 & 4 in a unilateral
arrangement so it's one hemisphere which
is the right hemisphere and if you roll
you can see that a lot of these channels
do we see a really there's a little bit
of a flurry of course we don't see
anybody up prominent peaks here and this
is in month three now in the next month
which
this month okay and a Taurus later a
month by the white ETFs word lots to 70
which is a tremendous Rob and here you
can see that there's a hero drive in the
gala band power of this patient and then
illness I start to take a look at the
y-axis here Grantham's are the 20 the
next slide is the same I just changed
the access so you can get a real feel
for how much the Gallup [ __ ]
increase and in particular I want to
draw your attention to child for where
you can see a tremendous increase in the
gallop and powering this was where we
have the highest sampling aside the
largest sampling of the neural
population of the senate-house so here
is an increase in government power which
Corwin's the decrease in the wipe ESS
score so in another patient where we do
not have a very good response to the
therapy especially what we see is again
this unilateral arrangement there show 1
2 3 & 4 as you saw before the white ETFs
score is high in two events is 1 3 and
um we got too much going on in the next
one which is on for the ultra dosing of
a tremendous change I'll go back and you
can see this from yg chance of 80 to go
to large Pierce's of Asians they've got
a big change in a logic chance for score
and there's also another big change in
the underlying physiology reduction gala
coming up
the following month again in Y GPSS of
only 78
not much of a change and you don't we
don't have and gallop Pony gallop keeps
here so we don't have a increasing gala
when you have a
benefit here we have another patient per
patient now
this patient has a white ESS score of 73
and this is also a 3 but I want you to
observe here though is that this is a
bilateral implant so the top to Welters
are the right hemisphere the bottom two
are the left hemisphere remember channel
1 is um some contacts women to tell to
school contacts 3 and 4 and then in the
left hemisphere similar challenges on
electrodes went to trial for electric
for poor and you see that there is um
again not any prominent activity a
little something in the alcohol but
nothing in the GABA then the following
note there is a change of one on the
wider chip some score from 73 72 and
then in month 5 we see this big change
in gamma from 70 to 256 as I can watch
differs from 72-56 and you can see that
in fact now you do have a change in
gamma again and in particular in the
left hemisphere where you have these
very strong allergies in particularly on
child of three sorry there's some
problem with huh now this is the
following looks like six or the white
ESS score goes back up and here we can
see that the gamma power goes away so
demo had shown itself when the white
ETFs work had dropped precipitously
so here is a waterfall showing you the
difference on the pre vdf and the post
DBS month six in the right panel you can
see all five patients the middle three
are the
with responders and these are after six
months of DBS currently BS therapy
except for ps2 just wanted to showed you
which on five peaked and then drop down
so you can see that the good responders
are showing the medical creasing down
power and which was not seen at all in
their previous and which we do not see
in the non-responders now before the
short-term stimulation we also know is
that short-term stimulation produce
increasing yellow band power and here
are what I want you to notice is the
left and right hemisphere and we took
one minute our resting state baseline
then this is a recording first then took
30 seconds of stimulation you can
simulation and then another 1 minute
of baseline and that's what you see in
the top middle and bottom panels this is
a home responder and one of our best
responders actually and this is 1 3 and
we have a lesson right hemisphere this
what you see on the left on the right
and you can see here that you have some
gamma in the wrestled a baseline of our
responder when they're simulation in the
middle panel there's a tremendous
increase in gamma on all four channels
during the different colors and then at
the second baseline post since you see
that there is now a residual and
increased stammer
in month six of that same patient you
see that the baseline gamma is a little
bit higher that there's again a strong
response to the pre second DBS there and
then again there is this residual gamma
so what we have in short term
stimulation that linux as it were what
we see in the product which is an
increasing downer power for those
patients who are responders when we look
at the theta activity we didn't see a
direct correlation with clinical benefit
but what we did see is that there are
two
yeah here we go so we look at the fate
of gala here and we compared to the
logic TSS course we see that the gala
has a direct correlation with the change
Velarde TSS with that the data is not
consistently changing in what direction
whatever I'll tell you only duplicate
the cross two types of correlations
there were direct correlations in David
gamma cross frequency power to the logic
TSS just as we've seen and being
download tell so what we can what our
results our conclusions are now we can
deduce from this is that VBS mediated
enhancement of gamma synchronization is
associated with the symptom relief he
owes a lot to that second we also found
that there is no direct clinical
correlation between products they have
and oscillations and the symptomatology
the underlying pathophysiology of GTS is
functionally expressed as the high
personal type of synchronization in the
grip of a very frontal cortical network
and we found this in the therapeutic the
brain stimulation could in fact correct
the dysfunction in the signal
transmission at the level propellers and
that all changed and that this was
altering the strength of the neural
coordination matrix as we discussed and
that children coordination was marked by
nano their transient changes during a
gala that might guide responsive
stimulation intraoperatively
to improve targeting tedious of GTF
revitalization of gibraltar etc this is
something that we look forward to
testing intraoperatively and for post
loop paradigms in the future this could
be helpful are also postoperatively by
giving a objective measure for
stimulation planter after the
stimulation powers and what will go is
the modulation of the gammas and
activity by deeper explanation of the
settlement
fellas is a key factor in mitigating the
pathophysiology associated with GPS so
with that I would like to end my talk
and thank you all for attending I also
like to give thanks to the team in
Florida who did the work that I just
described
Nicholas mei-ling who's now in Ohio and
Atkinson Justin Sanchez who's at DARPA
Mike Okin and Kelly foot and some people
from Europe Asia and the audience
Florida so is there any question thank
you for that presentation dr. hashemian
we want to get right to your questions
and input so here's a reminder on how to
let us know what you have to say
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left we will try to
get to all of you but if not we will be
sure to follow up after the broadcast
and now we'll get to our first question
how can you are did you verify that the
positive effects you see are due to the
stimulation rather than the surgery
itself okay so that's a very good
question
I imagine that what the person is asking
about it's something that's called the
micro regional effect so this is an
effect in which the patient will
experience the amelioration of symptoms
just by virtue of the surgery alone and
this can last up to a couple of months
or so typically if it does occur it
happens for a much much shorter period
of time one or two weeks the best way to
show that let me see if I can find a
slide for that the best way to show that
that was not the case is here with
patients - so in this case when we were
looking at the month before we saw that
there is a light ets escort 72 and there
were no prominent peaks and then in the
following month when the light of chance
has dropped we saw that there was this
increase in gamma but then when we went
to the following month after that the
white etfs went up again and they need
to see that the gamma is gone and this
cannot be the micro regional effect
because that would consistently be
showing something or it wouldn't be a
spike and then adopt again it would
correlate with the lighting cancers like
this so that's the best evidence for
this being a real effect versus just the
micro lesion effect and also these are
now months out so this is one five at
least see that effect so that wouldn't
be the micro regional effect same with
the other patients actually that I the
patient that I showed you that was in
month uh
you've shown very nice work shedding
light on the neurophysiological aspect
of pics but it's all from the Salamis
what about the cortex yes this is true
we were recording from the ceramic
Network one of the things that is
relevant is to look at the larger
network and in fact that's work that
we're doing here at the University of
Cologne and the department of stereo
taxi so in this little animation I have
a good slide for this to show you the
work that we're doing now this is a DBS
electrode which will go into the
d'Italia and will allow intracranial or
death recordings so here you can see
that I'm sorry I I think I got cut off
so here you can see the depth recording
and with that we combine with so you
have a submerged record and with that we
combined by adding an EEG which will
give us recordings from the cortex and
if we put those together then we can get
with the cortical subcortical Network
and an example of what that looks like
with high-density electrodes because
we're using 256 channels using the eg I
machine here you can see all the
different channels this is a raw
recording until you get to the very end
at the bottom on the over there you can
see those are the depth recordings that
are also together with the EEG and this
will allow us to to look at the large
scale Network and what is happening with
the dynamic changes in that network and
how the communication occurs between the
two areas I just want to show you this
slide also what it looks like when we
externalize the electrodes the way that
we're able to record from the
intracranial electrode is by extra
lysing that extension part that I was
talking to you guys about earlier and
that this is an example of Versailles
system from Boston Scientific so this
electrode is now coming out and you can
see their eight electrode contacts and
what we met reflects the eight electric
contacts that are inside the deep target
and together with the EEG we can as I
said get more information on the
functional connections and how they
change with the DBS therapy
next question please great thank you so
much for that answer our next question
is I next knew you could do chronic
recordings using DBS what are some of
the other advances and technology your
that are relevant for the treatment or
study of the human brain thank you so um
there are quite a few is a very exciting
time maybe s or quite a few new
innovations that are coming out the most
important of those is the what's called
the directional read or steered
stimulation and in that case so what you
saw when I just showed you the last
slide with eight electrodes on a lead so
have you excuse me more refined and in
what areas that you can record from and
stimulate will be extremely relevant so
here is an example from Abbott or what
was st. Jude of different electric
configurations for the directional lead
there called directional leads because
remember when I showed you
rampant fun yet here where you have the
nice electrical contact points in the
case of directional lead instead of
having just cylindrical contact point
what you have are segmented electrons so
instead of a full circle you've got
three segments that go around instead
and that's what you see here in the
middle of picture so the two Center
electrodes are actually segmented into
three parts and you can activate either
of those segments or all of them and
both abbott and Boston Scientific have
these systems right now available which
is wonderful and with Boston Scientific
we also have a constant current and have
a picture button to here's the system
right here and you can see the two
Center electrodes are segmented into
three pieces
and the piece that you see at the top is
for orientation so that you can know
which direction the electrode is and you
can know which segment you are
activating so that if you are getting
less near Parkington surgery it would be
you could get closer to the internal
capsule and you could steer away by
activating the segment that's on this
side where the stna the sephardic
nucleus and not activating the segment
of electrode that's close up against the
internal capsule therefore not getting
those side effects those caps were
effects so this sort of thing is
extremely useful and then if you can
also record from them you can record
from a more refined area of the target
or targets in which your implanted and
so you can get a better feel for what
the interactions are in the larger scale
Network that I was just discussing with
you and from the last question so I
think that these are really relevant for
the kinds of things that are coming up
also things like smartphone applications
I have this Saint Jude or what it now
Abuk infinity system this is already
available
what other things is doing
to have smaller and smaller IQ G's or
impressible plus generators and also
having access by smartphone so the
patients are able to tweak their
stimulation settings themselves a little
bit and instead of pulling out this
large device that could you know invite
questions what they can do with this
mark phone application or connected
technology is to be able to quietly and
without drawing attention to themselves
access their device and make corrections
as they see fit and I think that's
really relevant and also through the
connected technologies but I think
that's a very welcome resource for
patients especially that will have a
hard time making it to the proficient
office so information can be sent over
to the position from with an iPad or a
tablet and that will allow the physician
to optimize the settings for the patient
you know when they're sitting in their
office because that information that
information is sent over so I think
those things are really practically
relevant and now available and moving
forward and would be you know more and
more accessible through the different
companies the device that we use to be
able to chronicle coins two really
important because we discussed the
target localization our target selection
is is one of the most important things
that we have to focus on right now so
that we can be able to improve the
therapeutic window where the patient
gets the optimal effects and with
minimal side effects and I think that
having recording devices will help
people like myself who are trying to
understand the underlying
pathophysiology of these disorders which
we don't really know at all and the
better that we understand them the
better that the role we can improve
the surgical procedure to to improve
this therapeutic window so things like
clothes with stimulation being able to
understand for example the case of
Tourette's the gamma oscillations are
really relevant protects Genesis and
with and being able to intraoperatively
apprise the nerve surgeon yes you are in
the best possible target right now so
that when the patient is closed up and
has a stimulator everything internal or
implanted we know that we have the best
chance of improving the symptoms and the
disorder for the patient so Medtronic
had the PC plus s device which was CD
mark connecting approved but is not yet
it's not portion about like they're
coming out with their next-generation
device which will also I think include
closed-loop stimulation so these sorts
of things moving forward if it will be
really relevant for the future of DBS
one more question
great thank you so much for that answer
looks like we have time for one more
question and actually this is a two-part
question
the first part is did you use other
manufacturer electrodes as comparison
and the second part is why did channel 1
seem most effective in for channel
stimulations oh I guess so first other
questions did I use another
manufacturers electrode so that's not
possible
so with the neuro base device that is
quite different from the other devices
that are available on the market now
it's a responsive neurostimulator it's
the RNs system and it like the other
devices that I showed you the IPG you
know that they flex with their own
electrodes so you can't put for example
a Boston electrode with a Medtronic IPG
so the only device that you could record
from at that time was the narrow piece
device and you could only throw in
electrodes to be able to record and
stimulate so that's after that and then
the second part of the question was I
think that there was a stimulation on
channel 1 and recording on channel 4 or
something like this so let's clarify
that when we stimulate
we were simulating across the different
channels and we were also then recording
from those channels so the stimulation
wasn't specific to channel 1 and the
recording from channel 4 we actually
recorded from all the channels and then
that's what I showed you in the welding
spot is what we ended up seeing from the
life of a
of the electric recordings so I just
brought your attention to channel 4
because that was the large sampling of
the network and because we also saw the
greatest response there it implies that
this is in fact a large larger scale
Network phenomenon that's going on so do
you have anything else around up thank
you so much dr. Hashmi and do you have
any final remarks in to join in this
wonderful event and I'd like to thank
the viewers for coming to watch the talk
and I hope that this was helpful to
people who had any questions about the
underlying pathophysiology of threat
syndrome the functions of vapor ganglia
and also the efficacy of deep brain
stimulation which i think is a very
powerful tool for being able to not only
help patients who are medically
refractory but also to learn from the
procedure to improve as we move forward
for each patients and coming in I think
it's important to be able to really
maximize or optimize the tools that are
available to us for recording from the
human brains that we can improve
understanding of the human brain
dynamics
thank you once again dr. hashemian I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing on our
website through June 15 2017 we will let
you know when it's been posted then we
hope you pass that information on to any
colleagues who could take part in
today's broadcast see you next time
goodbye